something very interesting is happening
I've been crowing to anyone who would
listen for years but especially for the
last few months that we're at the apex
of meeting independent media corporate
media has failed systematically
ideologically and dramatically corporate
media was complicit in the DNC's handing
of the Democratic nomination to Bernie
Sanders corporate media didn't talk
about Bernie until there was no way to
avoid it they resisted until the last
possible day but then eventually they
just had to talk about Bernie corporate
media's reports on the horse race uh are
done in a way that conforms to very
narrow parameters in terms of what is
okay to discuss in these conversations
and I came to the audience when Trump
won even on election night and I said
it's so important right now to support
independent media and I am so heartened
that membership has exploded over the
last 48 hours I offered this forty
percent off deal which by the way if you
want email me and i'll send you the code
we're offering free david pakman show
calendars at david pakman.com slash
calendar 17 i don't know what the reason
is but it is exploding very special
thanks to nicholas hill pipra who signed
up at the highest level today a four
hundred and eighty dollars a year our
highest level membership I'm truly
flattered okay but it is fascinating to
me that now all of a sudden there are
some notable major articles coming out
worldwide about hey you know what we
need independent media I'm waving my
arms like a madman the entire elections
and corporate media has failed us we
need independent media especially when
it's trump or Clinton for different
reasons that we've talked about crickets
and now the Guardian publishes an
article called in this new world now is
the time to support fearless independent
journalism all now is the time at the
time wasn't when we were talking about
Bernie and corporate media didn't
mention him until they had no choice in
spite of a surge the last year was the
time for that kind of journalism and
every single corporate media outlet
failed the people and I think our
supporters but lots of people didn't
understand the importance now the
headline is right from the Guardian but
I want to look at one quote from the
article and talk about what they say
here uh this is an article by Lee
glendening
Lee glendinning that is in the Guardian
never has the world needed independent
journalism or through our reporting the
Guardian will hold trumpet in his
administration to account we will strive
to uncover the truth of those and if
those in power hide behind falsehoods we
will continue to sort fact from fiction
when underrepresented experiences are
ignored we will find ways to make sure
they are heard now is the time to
support journalism that is both fearless
and free which is why I am writing today
to ask you to fund our work by becoming
a guardian supporter I think what is
being missed here aside from whether you
consider the Guardian independent media
or corporate media doesn't really matter
the point is not about just holding
Trump a car accountable that's important
but the point is about laying the path
for the future and we can't wait until
August of twenty20 to start laying the
path on Monday I will come to you with
specific elections you can get involved
with now for 2018 and we will continue
laying out the path that we laid out
yesterday 20 18 20 20 20 20 to
redistricting the 2020 census we have to
think ahead in a real way and I'm going
to be doing it we're going to be working
on it but we do need your support I hope
that this experience for me it has
opened up my eyes to see what is
necessary if you're paying a hundred and
twenty bucks a month for cable TV is
another five bucks a month for a year of
the David Pakman show membership uh
going to but be something that doesn't
make any sense if you're paying a
hundred and twenty bucks for cable TV if
that's too much use the code hey tree at
40 and get forty percent off if you'd
rather get a free calendar i'll send you
a free calendar if you sign up at david
pakman.com slash calendar 17 but pat you
should see my email inbox dinging
constantly from new members and emails
from people saying I I realize that
corporate media f'ed us for realizing
that now yet if but CNN and the other
corporate media networks didn't give
Trump two billion dollars worth of free
advertising and rebuild itemizing
potentially three billion in free
advertising for Trump and not a mention
of Bernie until they just couldn't it it
they waited until they were going to be
red in the face from the fact
they were ignoring Bernie Sanders uh I I
really am glad I know that uh that
there's a lot of emotional stuff going
on I'm so glad about the fact that a lot
of people have come to me and they said
I'm supporting your show now I
understand the path forward I understand
we need to start working now please do
the same at david pakman.com slash
membership